haben wir bisher vielleicht mit den
falschen methoden nach aliens gesucht
finden wir mit unseren radioteleskopen
vielleicht gar keine signale und müssen
wir noch etwas ganz anderem suchen
das meinen jedenfalls die beiden
serbischen forscher milan cirkovic und
branislav micic sie glauben dass er ins
riesige schutzschilden ihre
heimatplaneten gebaut haben müssten die
wir nur zu suchen brauchen wieso weshalb
warum jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
unsere ehe wurde bereits viele male von
kosmischen katastrophen heimgesucht
asteroiden einschläge sind sicher
sternenexplosionen in der nähe
wahrscheinlich und gablitz sicher ist
mehrmals gab es ein massensterben hier
auf der erde und die ursachen dürften
oft aus dem weltraum gekommen sein
weiter entwickelte außerirdische
zivilisationen könnten dann gegen
schutzschilde gebaut haben damit
drohende katastrophen nicht ihre
zivilisation zerstören schon in den 60er
jahren gab es ja die idee dass
zivilisation riesige strukturen um ihren
heimatstern herum gebaut haben könnten
um energie zu gewinnen
die sogenannten weißen sphären bisher
wurden allerdings keine solchen sphären
gefunden obwohl beim stern hd 16 45 95
gibt es sehr seltsame schwankungen der
helligkeit teppichs stern manche
wissenschaftler wissenschaftlerin
schließen eine dyson sphäre dort nicht
aus und auch die neueste these eines
planeten mittring system das durch den
stern quasi durchgeknetet wird ist als
grund für die unregelmäßigen
helligkeitsschwankungen sehr umstritten
so oder so aber glauben die beiden
wissenschaftler dass außerirdische
intelligente wesen solche riesigen
struktur auf jeden fall zum schutz bauen
würden auch die menschheit vermuten sie
wird bald damit anfangen zum beispiel
könnten sie eine riesige schützende
struktur aus eisbrocken aus dem
kupfergürtel bauen die im falle eines
falles die erde schützen würde eine
solche wolke wäre so die forscher gar
nicht so aufwendig zu bauen
dementsprechend gehen sie davon aus dass
intelligente aliens längst solche
risiken strukturen gebaut haben und wir
nur nach danach suchen müssten ihre idee
zur verbesserten alien suche wir müssen
nur nach
sich anbahnenden kosmischen katastrophen
suchen und nach exoplaneten in der nähe
hier so müssten der gravitationswellen
im vorfeld der ereignisse selektieren
und dann die umgebung absuchen hier
müssen wir jetzt zum beispiel nach
helligkeit mustern suchen die solche
riesigen strukturen verursachen würden
zudem sollten wir nach infrarotstrahlung
suchen die durch solche strukturen
ausgesendet werden
es gibt mit diesem ansatz vielleicht
schnellere ergebnisse als wir bisher bei
der ebenso raten beziehungsweise wir
hatten ja keine und mit dem james webb
weltraumteleskop das im nächsten jahr
gestartet wird und alle bisherigen
weltraumteleskope bei weitem in den
schatten stellen wird werden wir auch
deutlich bessere chancen bei der alien
genre haben hierbei geht es um halte ich
euch natürlich dazu auf dem laufenden
wenn er kein video dazu und zu allen
anderen themen auf verpassen wollt dann
und mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesslich dem auf die glocke hier geht
es weiter mit finden wir noch dieses
jahr außerirdische eine verlockende
perspektive auf jeden fall also nicht
verpassen und draufklicken ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran